[Applause]
wow was that a backcourt that's what
quinn schneider was saying
murray for three got it as good a start
as he had he's disappeared here a little
bit
for the time murray butter hurry
around the oak screen hit him with the
hesitation move murray
oh he's on fire al murray has created
for you
he's got a longer defender on him than
joe ingles mitchell downhill
stopped on a dime no change for murray
just incredible shot making by two
separation with the step back how about
that
ridiculous stop and pull into your jump
shot motion
[Applause]
murray got all the way inside great
left-handed move
but boy oh boy what a possession
three-pointer
jamal murray pulls it back out against
dozier
clarkson kept it the entire possession
and a good decision
stayed between him and the basket boy
berry
feeling good offensively this time
defers to jokic and a good call jokic
with the three and the lead is up to
nine i mean this is a big
time delivery the connection is real
they're chemistry
[Music]
go bear i almost turn it over again and
it ends up in clarkson's hands and he
gets
an easy one 12 pounds stronger than he
was a season ago in the playoffs
looking for atonement this year juke's
ingles and he has it working
33 in the game for jamal murray
mitchell with a little get back got it
for a minute to go
off the yoke it's screen got free
raising up